and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 157 today
we're going to talk about reducing
excess stuff and and maybe we're gonna
even talk about reducing some of the
things that add value to our lives mmm
or maybe the things that we perceive add
value but our imaginary values in our
lives yeah it's funny what we can
justify you and I before the podcast are
we were doing this YouTube livestream we
call behind the scenes live and the
thing that I was trying to remind people
is that the lottery was I think 1.6
billion dollars
Squigs of B yeah and I just wanted to
remind folks that the lottery is a tax
on the poor hmm your four hundred times
more likely to get struck by lightning
than you are to win the lottery so if
you do win the lottery you're just as
likely to get hit by 400 lightning bolts
which why would you want that to happen
to you but you you were saying something
fascinating you were having dinner the
other night with Peter Rollins who was
on our podcast recently and he was
talking about not winning the lottery
but winning the lottery anyway yeah he
was talking with his friend about you
know what would happen if they won the
lottery and his buddy was talking about
all the things he would do with the
money
and then Peter Rollins was like wait a
minute man he's like you are debt-free
you live in Los Angeles you can afford
to live in Los Angeles you're spending
less than what you make he's like you've
already won the lottery man and is yoryu
so true as soon as you are living within
your means you have won the lottery in a
way I guess but well yeah because the
thing about winning the lottery is
having this financial freedom
now I understand lottery winners can buy
yachts and you know a front of me being
financial free right now does you know I
that includes a life without yachts
right but even if I could afford it I
wouldn't get it but but okay yeah but
yeah so so you being financially free
also means free in other ways as well
because
right the the implication of being
financially free has been less tethered
to either a lifestyle so in a weird way
that yacht can be a burden on people
especially when you start yeah if you
have a yacht you have to hire a
full-time crew and you have a captain
and you have people cleaning the boat
and you're paying for these people but
also you're managing them and and in a
way you're building up these you know
brick by brick by brick you're building
up these prison walls to be less free in
a way and you're being encumbered right
and burdened by the things that we
thought were going to make us free in
the first place yeah absolutely man I
mean yeah it's if you can I feel like if
I can live that free and I can save you
know each month for retirement I'm
spending less than what I'm making
then man like that's cut winning the
lottery on its own right or well I I get
so frustrated when I hear so many people
say it's just not realistic to live
debt-free but of course most people
throughout most of humanity all
throughout all of evolution until very
recently lived debt-free yeah and even
in the modern world the post
agricultural world within the last
10,000 years we've had homes we've been
tethered to one place but most of that
time we had no debt yeah at all well
it's definitely harder to lift up free I
mean I don't want to just you know make
it sound like it's a super easy thing to
do it's simple um I think that anyone
can do it it doesn't take you know so it
just takes someone who can form a plan
mm-hm and work that plan but but at the
same time it's it's harder to to work
that plan to be debt-free because it's
easy to go in today yes
but it's actually harder on you if you
are in debt it's harder on you
psychologically emotionally certainly
financially when when we are in debt and
I think one of the keys what we're gonna
be talking about today is the excess
stuff in our lives so let's talk about
what excess means at first because my
excess might be different from your
excess right Ryan so so for me the might
imposed definition of excess here is
excess is that which does not add value
to our lives and so when we talk about
what adds value does it serve a purpose
so if I have a pin that serves a purpose
its adding value to my life or does it
bring me joy yeah we were at your house
yesterday recording some living room
conversations for YouTube and you have
some artwork on the wall I may not have
a particular function necessarily but it
does it does serve a different purpose
right where it brings you joy that
aesthetic pleasure and so in a way you
could even argue that it does have a
function it does serve a purpose it it
enhances the aesthetics or the beauty of
your home yeah and so that's what excess
is in the the terms of today and I found
this video someone actually it was our
friend Mike Adkins send it over to me
very strangely and it I didn't know at
the time we were gonna be doing an
episode about excess but it is the
perfect video to describe well this
human condition of I think we're drawn
to access in a way so let's take a look
yeah let's check it out whether you
drive a fox wagon or you drive a Bentley
the road remains the same isn't it
[Music]
whether you speak on a Samsung or you
speak on an iPhone X whoever you're
calling remains the same whether you're
flying economy or you're flying business
the destination area heading remains the
same isn't it whether you're wearing a
simple fast track all you wear an Omega
or a Rolex the time remains
it's quite amazing how we work ourselves
up so much with increasing the standard
of living that we forget to increase the
standard of our life and which is why
wherever I travel I make an appeal to
people there's nothing wrong with an
Omega nothing wrong with a Bentley god
bless you with that and if you have it
private no problem but it is trying to
enhance and increase and improvise a
standard of your living please please do
not compromise with the standard of your
life it's not the standard of your
living that makes you happy it's a
standard of your life that makes you
happy and very often we forget to give
attention to those things that can truly
make us happy which is why I always say
things that I'm talking about they have
utility value right not happiness value
travel business was a first-class travel
no problem drive apparently no problem
but in doing so never ever compromise on
those principles that also improve the
standard of your life and therefore I
always say some people are so poor so
poor so absolutely for that all they
have is money
that's all that's all I consider that
life of our district in life if all you
have is money you're the poorest person
in the world because there's more to
life than money and there's way more to
life than what money can buy and
therefore a many times say if you want
to truly know how rich you are drop it
here and see how many hands come forth
to wipe that deal ladies and gentlemen a
happiness a happiness and I increased
and of life is not in things it's in
people it's relationships it's
meaningful heartfelt deep bondings of
love that bring fulfillment to the heart
is those meaningful exchanges of love
that we share with each other and
relationships that brings true joy to
the heart and isn't it the greatest
irony it's something that brings in the
greatest fulfillment be very
conveniently neglect in just running
after increasing and enhancing a
standard of living wow man
have you seen that one before I haven't
and I had neither and the a few things
that stood out to me were he he sort of
differentiated with some wordplay
they're the standard of living versus
the standard of life yeah if I were to
append that a little bit I would just
say that the don't don't sacrifice your
standards for a standard of living you
and I often talk about raising your
standards but but lowering the
expectations and right now we have so
many expectations we have these excess
expectations or better yet we have these
expectations of excess if I win the
lottery I can get that yacht I can buy
the mansion and just before this you
revealed to me that if you won the
lottery accidentally I don't know how
you would but maybe you walked by the
winning ticket you picked it up and all
of a sudden you realize like I am one
point six billion dollars richer your
life would not change appreciably from
Hallett chain
right now you might have a slightly
newer car you might have a might have a
own a house yeah I own a house instead
of renting one being able to own a house
outright but not at a considerably
different dwelling from what you live in
now in terms of square feet or or
opulence you're probably not gonna go
buy a mansion in Beverly Hills with that
money but as he said in that video
there's nothing inherently wrong with
the house or the car or whatever it's
when we put those things first when we
think that that excess as well as what
allows us to succeed and and in our
society in our culture the trinkets of
success are are the things that we use
to measure our lives but they're not a
measurement of fulfillment or joy or
happiness they're a measurement
measurement of material wealth yeah but
I think he put a great I mean he what
was his name oh it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's okay if you don't
know his name but but you know what he
did is he did a great job of explaining
how Hey look yeah it's okay to have the
Bentley drive a Bentley it's okay to
it's okay to wear role looks if that's
what you want to wear it's okay to fly
first-class the problem is when we
forsake our did he say our principles
yeah he did say principles yeah and what
he called the the standard of life
that's really what he was talking about
is having your principles what you and I
would refer to them as values now we
would delineate different types of
values that we could talk about those
today when we're answering some of these
questions and the thing that really
stood out to me is he said that that
some people are so poor is that all they
have is money you know and if you have
all all you have is money then you're
the poorest person in the world yeah a
man that does stuck with me because we
can have excess and we get to these
points where we we we amassed the excess
the average American house has 300
thousand items in it it didn't happen
overnight you didn't go out and buy 300
thousand things at Home Depot and
Walmart this weekend it happened over
years decade
several decades sometimes and so you get
to that point where you're like my mom
when she passed she was 65 years old and
she had 65 years worth of accumulations
in a tiny one-bedroom apartment and she
wasn't a hoarder she just held on to
things she had excess she had 14 winter
coats in her closet and she lived in
Florida she had these things that she
wasn't using didn't make her a bad
person didn't even make her wrong it
just meant that that like most of us and
I think this is the human condition we
when we don't when we don't stop
ourselves and we'll stop back we always
want the new thing and it drives forward
innovation yes the reason we have all
these really we have these cool
microphones and we have like we have
this the sound panels we I have a iPhone
in my pocket and it's because like we
crave innovation and we go for more more
more and more that becomes a problem
when it's unchecked when we when we
don't start thinking about why do I need
this this new thing yeah I know you have
an older version of the iPhone yeah it's
it's a few versions old yeah and and
there and for you right now there isn't
a good reason for you to upgrade to a
new one
now for me in my current situation I
upgraded last year whenever the the 10
counts of the version before the one
that's the the three newest ones now the
access whatever the first version of the
ten yeah the 10 one 1x so confused right
now yeah I don't know but for me they're
there a couple things on there that have
really aided my relationships personally
and I say relationships for my
relationship with my partner backs which
I could be fine with an old flip phone
with her but with Allah like I was on
FaceTime with her last night and it has
the an emoji feature and yeah she was
having a meltdown before I called her
and you know she's in a different city
right now and and when I called her I
was able to put the dragon and emoji on
and so I was a dragon as I talked to her
oh and it was a
was extremely valuable like to have her
laughing but in the conversation because
she was having a bad day yesterday and
so sometimes these things can aid our
life and so you and I aren't aren't
going to say hey get rid of all of your
things everything is excess the question
is does it actually bring any sort of
value to your life yeah all right man
what do you think we should get into
these questions about excess yeah let's
do it our first question today is from
Abby in Alberta Canada I've been a
lifelong minimalist at heart so
simplifying my life and identifying
values has always been really easy for
me and I only really owned things that
really bring value into my life at this
point but what brings the most value
also brings a lot of agitation and
compulsion when I lose them or they
break this this partly has to do with a
mental illness but you know things like
hair ties t-shirts pens
I have favorites of those things and
I'll lose them break them and I just you
know I just can't focus so I try to
distract myself meditate eggs and even
consider just removing all things that
are my favorite but the thing is when
they're not broken and lost and and
whatnot they bring so much volume into
my life and so I'm just really torn
about how to bring calm into my life
without just getting rid of everything
our value so here's the thing she said
she's a life long minimalist at heart
and and I appreciate the sentiment but
here's what I'll say minimalism isn't in
the heart it's in the actions yeah it's
just like that's like saying I'm a
carpenter at heart right but like really
you're a carpenter only if you take the
actions to build things and minimalism
is is a tool in a way and as a
minimalist I use minimalism to to
simplify my life now I can actually I
can really identify with Abby because I
have you know I have OCD I have many of
the same compulsions and she in fact
even mentioned some of the things that
yeah having the
here I don't have hair ties but like she
said pins and and it's funny that we got
this question right now because just
this past week I at home got rid of all
of my pins that weren't uniform you come
into the office here we have uniform
pins yes and it's because I have I have
the same sort of neurotic struggles that
that Abby has here and so what I do is I
make sure when I have multiples of
something whether it's underwear shirts
I'm trying to socks yeah yeah whatever
it is yeah socks is a really good
example pins
whenever I have multiples of something I
make sure they're all the same because I
know other backs could care less if they
we have all the same and and that does
two things for me one is I have the
optimal version of what I want right
right I don't have just well there's a
collection of hair ties or pins or
underwear that some of us underwear some
come from well I might as well hold on
to it or whatever no no I have I have
the ideal one and then I also know when
I lose it or break it I know what to
replace it with yeah when my underwear
rips or whatever I decide you know I had
to bring more underwear back in my life
I know exactly I don't want to go out
there and in a roast over which type
should I get we should I try something
new this time the beauty about
minimalism I remember we talked to Frank
who's in our documentary minimalism our
Netflix documentary and he Frank isn't a
minimalist architect and we were sitting
on his couch in his living room and he
said it took me three years to find this
couch and I couldn't find it so I had it
built oh wow
and I I did that took so much time
invested this time and effort so I would
never have to think about it again
I'm not gonna have to replace this couch
for the next 10 20 years because I'm
dissatisfied with it and the same should
be true for the little things in our
lives even if it's a pin or a hair tie
or a t-shirt
I have multiples of the same thing and
when they wear out or they break or I
lose it I can just say let go of it
bring a new one in it's totally okay I
totally I totally agree man it's like
with my black t-shirts I might try a new
brand right and then maybe that new like
I'll get one of the new brain to try it
out and then all of a sudden that
becomes my favorite black t-shirt let's
talk about that and I go and I get
multiple versions of that black t-shirt
and you had this happen so this is a
good example let's say they stopped
making this pin they stopped making the
the shirt that you bought in fact while
the quality reduced the company sort of
changed hey guys I switch brands and and
this is fun when the quality reduced you
were like I'm actively going to find a
new brand now but with the intent of I
want to find the brand that I can
continue to buy not because you have
brand loyalty but because it makes the
decision-making process easy and you
you're not going to continue to
experience decision fatigue what happy
is experienced in here right now is
excess fatigue yeah absolutely I mean
that well the other thing to men is I
it's it's well there's experiment you
did was really interesting right you had
your favorites you had that article that
you did when we first started the
minimalist stuff this was back in 2008
when t11 and they asked you well you
know what are your favorite things and
you're like here these pair of shoes
pair of jeans here's a shirt and then
you were like wait a minute like these
are my favorite things I'm putting a lot
of meaning on these I wonder what it'd
be like to just get rid of these
favorite things yeah well I think that's
important because we do often couple
meaning with our things but the truth is
our things don't have any meaning other
than the meaning we give to them so I
had my favorite shirt then right I had
my favorite pair of Allen Edmonds dress
shoes I'm my favorite pair of j.crew
jeans and when when that journalist
asked me or the blogger asked me hey cuz
it was one of those weird things where
was like hey as a minimalist what are
your favorite things and I'm like yeah I
do have some favorite things here's my
favorite shirt is my favorite jeans here
my favorite shoes and then as I was
typing this up to him and sending him
pictures I'm like well wait a minute why
are these my favorite things well
because I get more value from them than
the other things but I realize like well
wait a minute they're just things and
because they're a fate that it's a
favorite thing if what if I got rid of
it then I could get rid of the meaning
I'm giving to these things it was an
exercise and letting go not of the
things necessarily but of the meaning
and guess what new
jumped up and became my favorites if I
were to hold on to those right now
I highly doubt they'd still be my
favorite Jean right or my favorite she's
been holding on to him for no reason
yeah there's almost 10 years ago
something else definitely would have
taken their place so Abby we're not
telling you to get rid of your favorite
things but she did ask she's like you
know I just don't want you know should I
get rid of my favorite things and it's
like if they're your favorite things
that's fine hold on to them but if you
if they're causing you pain then then
maybe you want to rethink how much
attention you're giving those items like
I know for me with the more I kind of
keep my thoughts going on and get
focused on one thing like I started a
roast over it and and I know that Abby
said she's got a little bit of a mental
illness so you know my question would be
is how can I neuro slash I know
meditation definitely helps with that
for sure but in the same token to like
you want a little friction you want a
little pain you want a little you want a
little bit of discomfort right yeah I
think so like you just don't want things
to be super easy but but Abby it's it's
ultimately it's it's sunk cost when you
lose those things but you know if you
have to be willing to let it go yeah if
you've got a favorite hair tie though
Abby then by multiple multiples of that
hair type I think it rid of the ones
that aren't your favorite yeah it's
gonna it's gonna simplify its kind of
streamline the the collection of things
you have and you're not gonna be worried
about losing them because you'll realize
that they are just things Abby I'd love
to send you a copy of our book it's
called essential there's a whole chapter
actually if you're watching us on
YouTube I think I have a copy of it here
Sean was kind enough to set these off
for us it is an essay collection called
essential and what camera shall hold us
up to Jordan this one here all right
there we go it is called central it's a
hundred and fifty essays about
intentional living but there's an entire
chapter in here about stuff and since
you're dealing with your stuff right now
Abby I think you'll find value in that
so we'll either send you the book book
or if you like this podcast you're
probably like the audiobook version of
that book as well it's our longest book
it's over a six-hour audio book or if
you want the eBook version then we're
happy to send that to you as well Sean
if you'd reach out to Abby send her a
copy of essential essays by the
minimalists all right our next question
is from Tiffany
in Pasadena so I have a lot of handbag
designer and they're very expensive and
they're just sitting in my closet but
I'm not sure what to do with them I do
think that I will eventually maybe give
it to my daughter if I ever have kids
but um but I don't want to get rid of
them um I did get him from from my mom
so uh so what should I do with them
alright Tiffany I am truly perplexed by
your question I'm confused because
you're calling us up and just telling us
you want to keep your stuff your ask us
what you say I want to keep them but
what should I do
well if you want to keep your stuff then
keep your stuff Ryan and I aren't here
to be the stuff police we're not the
excess police today we're trying to help
you out however here's my my big butt
here however if you're calling us up
it's telling me that these things are
causing enough discontent in your life
that you want to do something with them
and that something isn't what you're
currently doing with them which is you
have you're basically you've turned your
house into a storage locker for
expensive designer and very expensive
yes designer handbags are sitting in
your closet and they might go to some
hypothetical daughter that you may or
may not have and here's the other thing
your mom gave these to you you based on
your voicemail are currently not getting
any value from them and now you want to
give them to someone else who is likely
also not going to get about any value
from them based on your own experience
well this is this is difficult really it
sounds like because you know she doesn't
want to let down her mom right yeah like
her mom gave her that's the implicit
question right yeah and you know it's
it's so hard man when a family member or
a friend
you know someone gives you something
that means a lot to them I mean I still
have a bunch of handbags you gave me I
don't know what I do but you know it's
like I could see where Tiffany would be
like oh wow mom like these mean a lot to
you that's that's awesome yeah thank you
thank you for giving me something that
means a lot to you and I understand that
transaction part of it but when we go
with the flow like that well we find us
you know we find ourselves being in a
situation like Tiffany is so I don't
know how you would approach this Josh I
can say how I did approach it recently
so I would I would do what one of two
things I'd either accept the fact that
I'm going to have these handbags and
figure out a way to keep them that is
going to be you know the easiest way to
keep them I mean that doesn't sound like
what Tiffany wants to do but if it's
that important to her to keep these
these these heirlooms or I guess they're
starting to become heirlooms then oh
wait hold on let's let's take that line
of thought for a second okay creating
heirlooms isn't actually creating
heirloom yeah that's true that is so
true man yeah that's how something
becomes an heirloom right yeah so so
Tiffany if that is the case though then
yeah like it's keep them but you've got
to look in the mirror anytime you get
frustrated with those handbags and
you've got to say I'm doing this to
myself I'm deciding to hold on to these
so that's option number one option
number two is she can completely get
those out of her life the way I would do
it personally is I would go to my mother
and I would say hey I know that these
handbags mean a lot to you but to be
honest they are stressing me out because
I have to store them I don't use them
they are causing a lot of anxiety in my
life and I really really want to I want
to get them out of my home do you mind
holding on to them until I might have a
daughter one day that's something you're
willing to hold on to these are so
stressful that I'm calling up a couple
of 37 year old guys from Ohio and asking
them what I should do with them right
they're clearly not adding value to your
life and that's the problem if you were
getting value from them it just goes
back to that video you have
Bently of handbags is sounds like or
several Bentley's yeah you're like
though who was the guy in the wild wild
country with 42 Rolls Royces no show yo
show I and and here's the thing like if
you were getting value from these gray
ever my former spouse she loved having
all these different handbags yeah and
like she uses them all the time and I
mean great if you're gonna use them
wonderful but but collecting is just
well planned hoarding yeah and
ultimately too late don't let someone
else's feelings I don't know if I'm
wearing this right maybe not me were
this better Josh but letting someone
else's feelings towards an item transfer
to yourself it's like if those handbags
mean a lot to her mom like that's great
like if she really likes them and uses
them and you know great but but don't
take it upon yourself to phanie to make
it make yourself feel like you have to
appreciate them the same exact way that
your mom does physical attachment to
material items is non-transferable yeah
absolutely
there you go there's a little maxim for
you pocket so what did you you said you
had this happen recently so very
recently so when we were moving so last
year we were moving in the back of my
junk drawer was my mom's wedding diamond
wedding ring it was a really nice
wedding ring and small my mom was you
know 411 yeah and and she had I remember
having it but I didn't remember still
having it like I didn't remember ever
getting rid of it either but just it I
just stopped thinking about it right
after my mom passed I brought it back to
to Dayton and then it traveled with me
to Montana and then I found it in the
back of the drawer and in in the box it
was this little box and my wedding ring
was in there too from my first marriage
oh wow
and I'm like first I didn't think it was
mine I thought I got rid of that III but
then again I didn't remember getting rid
of it but just like a lot of the things
when I was getting rid of things like at
some point of it was just snowball I
couldn't get rid of this go go go go
everything must go I was having a fire
sale and and so I I was like well we
just need to get rid of the dough
my ring and then with my mom's ring I'm
like I had the same feelings as Tiffany
mm-hmm well what if I have a daughter
someday that wants us maybe this will be
great for Ella and when she gets married
20 years from now and then I'm like wait
a minute like I don't need to create an
heirloom someone could get value from
this right now so I have a niece her
name is Kiva well my brother Jerome he
has a daughter who is getting ready to
graduate high school this year and so as
an early graduation gift I gave this
this ring to her I wrote her this this
beautiful note about how I'm how much my
mom loved her and cared for her when she
my mom raised Kela yes and and babysat
her a lot and now she's gonna have a
piece of that I know she's going to get
value from way more than if it just sits
in a drawer or a closet or an attic
somewhere so my message to tiffany is
this can someone else get value from
these someone you know someone who's
close to someone you know and maybe you
can contribute beyond yourself in a
meaningful way by letting go absolutely
Tiffany I'd love to send you a copy of
our book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've ever written
it's right here if you're watching this
on youtube we'll send you the audiobook
version of that there's an entire
chapter in here about dealing with
sentimental items specifically what I
had to do with my mom stuff it was my
first journey into minimalism before I
even knew it was called minimalism and
and and dealing with the death of a
loved one but also dealing with her
stuff and especially dealing with her
sentimental items because by the way
when someone dies instantly everything
everything starts to become sentimental
right like I can't get rid of her her
yarn that I'll never use because it's
her yarn and what about this doily or
whatever these things I know I'm never
going to use yeah and so Tiffany enjoy
that copy of everything that remains
will send you the audiobook the book or
the e-book whatever you'd like
all right y'all we'd love to hear what
you have to say so if you have a comment
or tip about excess including advice for
any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast
the minimalists calm it's my favorite
part of the show will air our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
and at the end of this episode so stay
tuned for this week's listener comments
and tips Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is Millie it is time for
our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we're on Twitter Facebook and Instagram
at the minimalists during the lightning
round this was a Ryan and I each do our
best to answer every question but just a
short shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text of these
middle Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our put the answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our minimal Maxim's
in one place minimal maxims dot-com all
right our first lightning round question
is from kotti should I minimize
everything at once or gradually well let
me start with my pithy answer because
it's a paradoxical pithy answer I've no
alliteration Ryan I like it
alright it is this letting go is
instantaneous letting go takes forever
and well say is you not only should you
do both you kind of have to do do both
yeah even if man there's we just got a
message from someone on Instagram
what's the island next to Guam Saipan
correct just was hit by the hurricane oh
yeah and they were just showing us
pictures of all like the devastation and
they said hey because of you I'm able to
let go of this so in a way they had to
let go of this instant I literally
physically had to let go of it because
they couldn't hold on to it yeah but
letting go also takes time emotionally
psychologically spiritually there is a
untethering and uncoupling you will do
even after you let go of the physical
item so letting go does happen
instantaneously but it will can you'll
continue to let go emotionally for a
long period of time and I know with you
Ryan you you you did your packing party
that was a way to let go relatively
quickly relatively immediately but then
of course the process of letting go
never stopped you didn't get rid of
everything and said I'm never gonna buy
anything else again and I'm never going
to let go or donate anything else again
it continues to be a
process right yeah absolutely man well
yeah well here's my pity answer a plan
is helpful only if implemented so you
know ultimately doesn't matter if you
look go quickly it doesn't matter if you
let go over time the important part is
is that you commit to how you want to
bring things into your lives how you
want to remove things from your lives
right and and and implement that plan
cuz for me yes I did everything
instantaneously I have to sometimes do
you know something extreme to really
change my state where with you you did
the exact opposite right but here's the
here's the weird thing so you and I had
different approaches it took me eight
months to let go in retrospect I wish I
would have done what you did in fact I
would hurt even quicker right because
it's it's the the pulling off of the
band-aid I I pulled mine off all and you
know one setting and I didn't slowly rip
out it over many days so to speak to
continue the metaphor but with you you
just ripped it off quickly got it out of
the way and and I just read Cal Newports
new book and it's it's about digital
minimalism it's coming out next year I
can't wait to talk more about it but one
of the things he does it doesn't there
he had 16 people participate in this
experiment of digital minimalism and and
letting go and he he made people sort of
do the radical thing the packing party
version of minimizing the digital side
of well I think when we do those radical
things to like it helps us really get
clear on what truly is adding value yeah
I mean that's exactly why he did it I
yeah okay so so so I think I think the
advice here is do everything at once if
you can but more important than that I
totally agree with Ryan have a plan and
then execute implement that plan
absolutely all right our next question
is from Angela would you please talk
about why getting rid of excess stuff is
so emotional for many of us I'm ready
and I'm actively doing it but I cry
letting go of so many things
it hurts to let go man so I'm sorry that
you're hurting I totally I understand it
though it's weird because as we let go
that's when we we start
giving meaning to things even more yeah
we give them more meaning than they
initially gave them although I've
already said that the things don't have
meaning themselves we've given the thing
some meeting but then what it's time to
let go we / value that meaning even
greater right yeah and so my pithy
answer for you Angela is letting go of
stuff hurts only when we conflate
material with meaning and it's you know
easier said than done right man I mean
it's like I got that Stein that I talk
about often that my grandma gave me from
high school pen Stein
it just holds you know it's from Germany
it's it's got the coat of arms from
where you know our family comes from and
lawn suit Germany and I use it there for
my change and you know it's it is I do I
don't want to say overvalue it but you
know if it broke you know if the
spontaneously combusted I would I would
probably flinch but ultimately because
you know you and I have been practicing
not creating these emotional bonds with
things that the flinch wouldn't last as
long so I guess I'm just not trying to
make it sound super super easy it is
it's definitely difficult but the more
you practice the easier it is but here's
here's my pity answer I would say create
an emotional bond with people not things
I mean it's very similar to our love
people use things but that's exactly why
we say that yeah it's because what you
said earlier sometimes we over value
things and when we were talking to Peter
that's what love is love is over valuing
something and if we're over valuing
material possessions we are falling in
love with our things and if that's what
we choose to perpetuate that feeling
that emotion that connection with a
thing Wilmette I mean we have to realize
what that what that connection is
actually going to do to us totally green
PS Ryan we have one more question about
XS sue me asks I'm a person who loves
fashion and clothes oh but I also
realize I have an unnecessary amount of
excess clothes that I don't use how do I
find balance how can I be a fashionista
and not buy clothes
I would consider myself a fashionista
consider you one as well right answer
this question I'm looking forward to
this because I have I have some choice
words to say to sue me here but I have
some helpful advice that I think it will
really be able to tweet us out if you'd
like to hear our answer to that question
you can listen to this week's PostScript
episode over at the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively to our
patreon supporters so if you want to
support our show and keep this podcast a
hundred percent advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our ask
the minimalist anything episodes that's
just for our patreon supporters to ask
the minimalist anything we're gonna
write a record one next week actually
Ryan asked the minimal is anything those
unreleased recordings of our live events
we've had over 15 live events out there
in the last year just for our patreon
supporters and you can check out the
entire back catalog of past private
episodes there's over 80 past private
episodes out there right now so if one
dose of minimalism is not enough for you
every week you can get a second podcast
every single week on the minimalist
private podcast feed oh and once you
become a supporter you'll receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feed so the plays in your normal podcast
player whatever you're using to listen
to this podcast right now you can find
all the details and all the good stuff
over at the minimalists comm slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
I think that being a fashionista isn't
the goal the same way being a minimalist
is not the goal right doesn't mean you
can't be a minimalist or you can't be a
fashionista but that should not be the
goal because you you are not a brand and
you're not earning a living from these
brands in fact you're doing the opposite
you're earning a living to support these
brands in a way okay now it's time for
our added value portion of the show we
were just talking about circumcision
during the patreon so so we'll see how
that plays out
speaking of excess anyway this is where
we each talk about some of those added
value to our lives
recently man I've got something that I
try to I try to look at different
perspectives on likewise on not just
politics but life in general I want to I
want to be bombarded with relevant
perspective yes in my life so that I
choose only one perspective like if
you're choosing one perspective only
like you're you're doing yourself a
disservice what's that yeah the
confirmation bias and in today's society
is aided by our technology because it
allows us to select only the things that
we agree with or we can hate watch
things that we disagree with
like if you're a super conservative you
can go to mother jones and be like look
how stupid these liberals are or if
you're a conservative or if you if you
are a liberal you can you can go to like
the Drudge Report and say look how
stupid these conservatives are all right
but that's not helpful no what I look
for helpful perspectives on different
things and our friend Lewis house who's
been on the podcast before he did he
brought Glenn Beck into his house to
talk about what Glenn Beck has a new
book out called addicted to outrage
which reminds me of an essay that we
wrote a few years ago called fake
outrage and I'll tell you he talked he
talked a lot about the current climate
the current culture and whatever you
think of Glenn Beck sometimes we think
of some
like him as a sort of parody of himself
well I remember when you were telling me
about this episode this podcast it was I
was like isn't that ironic he's got this
book addicted to rage but he kind of
added I would say he's someone who added
to the rage you know years ago yeah yeah
well absolutely and that's what he's
talks about in this interview with Lewis
Howes like cuz he's he's in this he
everyone hates him hmm
and one of them one of things he talked
to I think the year was 2007 I might
have some of the details wrong but
according to I believe Time magazine or
one of these were big reports he was the
fourth most influential person in the
country yeah and he was also the second
most disliked person it's gonna be sent
really like half the country loved him
and half the country hated him in a way
and that was odd to me but the other
thing that was odd to me is when he was
talking about is is in 2016 during the
Trump
election during when he was he was
running for president like Glenn Beck
was he's a conservative guy like super
conservative yeah but also he was super
anti Trump hmm because he was standing
on particular principles but he also
realized after the fact that like the
way he was was behaving during that time
was sort of divisive and fueling the
outrage that that you're talking about
he wasn't listening to the people who
were supporting him and and that's the
thing that we're not doing and so one of
the things he talks about in this
interview with Louis Howe so I'll put a
link to this in the show notes as well
as everything else we've talked about
today in the show notes but the things
he talked about was how some of his
childhood trauma or trauma through his
mom killed herself and a few things
happen in his life where that lent
itself to this sort of polarization for
him and acting out as he was a we grew
up poor but light became wildly
successful early in his radio career and
was making really good money in his
early 20s sound familiar
yeah and then all of a sudden like no
one could tell him anything and
everything he did he thought was gold
and and he created this own trauma for
himself as well
and then fueled the sort of outrage and
now we're in this sort of culture that
doesn't listen we we we don't do a good
good enough job of listening and
listening has become this fine art the
very few people are Conda sewers of
listening these days
yeah and so one things you can do is is
find these intelligent alternate
perspectives so we'll put a link to this
podcast interview I thought it was
really good
lewis howes interviewing glenn beck
about trauma and addiction to outrage
you know it's interesting about outrage
someone who is you know outwardly
expressing their rage it's doing two
things it is a it's fueling the people
who agree with them right like it is
it's encouraging those people to get
angry at people who don't agree with
this this rage essentially and then the
second thing it does is the the people
who don't agree with it it it just
pushes them further away from from
understanding whatever it is that you're
trying to say right and it's it's I
guess it's just my way of saying is when
we express outrage we're just adding to
the problem there is there's there's
nothing I mean correct me if I'm wrong
but I can't think of anything that you
know expressing outrage would give us an
advantage on it's not helpful sometimes
in the moment it can it can quash a
argument or keeps in a weird way it can
keep something from escalating in the
moment the long term it's going that
thing that is going to stew the enraged
person yeah he's going to outrage even
worse later on and we're separating
people in the camps and I'm really I'm
realizing this now where there are are
these sort of it's not just political
but there are these fringe sort of
groups gonna really really loud the
outraged friend right but most of us
ninety percent are probably eighty
percent there's ten percent on each
fringe and the 80 percent of us that are
left
we're not the outraged ones but we get
affected by the people on on the margins
and we get we get down because we see
this on the news and that and by the way
the news is culpable not because of fake
news or whatever else I mean
obviously be a part of it but the the
breaking news is more of a problem than
fake news because what the hell is
breaking it with if if news is always
breaking then it's broken mmm tweet that
podcast Shawn yeah ma'am well it's yeah
it's it's it's unfortunate when we see
on the news no matter what no matter
what new source you're looking at when
we see outrageous headlines and
outrageous stories it almost forces us
to try and choose a side and if we you
know put our plan our flag with anyone
perspective like you've I feel like
you've already lost yes yeah because
that means you're not willing to listen
right all right what about you Ryan you
you have something that's a more a bit
more upbeat for us ya know so uh Khalid
one of one of my favorite artists how
old is he he's probably 18 now 19 no
he's probably somewhere on their pride
20 21 so yeah he put out he put out an
album a couple years back called
American teen yeah he was 18 at the time
was one of my favorite like such a good
album like upbeat really really awesome
he just came out with a new I guess it's
an EP it's got like seven tracks well if
Kanye West made it to be an album right
right those albums are seven tracks but
it I don't know if it I don't know the
difference anymore between an album and
EP and mixtape and I don't think my list
especially with the climate now it's
like you can put out whatever you
wouldn't call it whatever you want yeah
and but the thing that I like the
description of it that I saw on on
iTunes and they didn't call an album a
playlist EP is set a love letter to his
hometown of El Paso Texas and it's it is
that I I felt I felt really good about
when I want listen to this I felt like
he had he'd matured a lot don't you
think yeah yeah it's good it's it's
different from American teen it's a
little bit slower but it's still good
album it's called Sun City and it just
came out pretty recently how about we at
the end of this we will play
I think the first track is called is it
called man I think it's yeah vertigo
let's say at the very end of this
episode we'll play and wade out we'll
play you out with some vertigo alright
let's let's move on to right here right
now where we talk about what's going on
of the minimalists screen 'less
Saturday's is still happening for us if
you want to learn more about that it's
just the minimalists comm slash screen
lists and we're getting lost a little
bit on the weekends and finding out that
it's okay to get lost although I'll tell
you man you know what I've I've I've
realized what's a I'm less productive
now that we're doing screen those
Saturdays because I work a lot yeah and
for me having my computer off for entire
36-hour period basically I think it's
healthy for you though man it's probably
healthy for me it's taken a bit of
adjusting and although I know that we're
doing a simple year which by the way
this last year for a simple year next
year 2019 if folks are interested in
that when does this come out this come
out and time oh yeah you saw early
registration ends November 13th if
you're interested in that just head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
simple year what that is it's 12 months
of guided simplicity it's a it's a new
course that Ryan and I are working on
we're doing the the 2018 one right now
we're doing a course on gift-giving and
man we go really really deep into a lot
of fun yeah into the gift-giving 2019 s
last time to doing it and my partner
Rebecca is is taking on a month next
month as well so it's twelve different
months led by twelve different experts
now next month we're gonna have to break
our screen with Saturday or I should say
this month November we're going to break
our screen with Saturday rule for an
hour or two because we're teaching a
live workshop now that's something
that's on Friday the night that we're
doing one on eight we're doing two in
November we're doing one on a South okay
I got you you talking about the other
one okay I got ya so we're doing two
workshops and one of them that was on
the Saturday but otherwise yeah and I
think that's what we're learning is
sometimes there are times where you have
to sort of break your own self-imposed
rules but these rules aren't religious
rules they're boundaries and sometimes
it's okay to step out of bounds as long
as you're doing so with intention yeah
and man I've only I've learned a whole
lot we talked about it on past episodes
but if you want to join us in that share
it with us on social media you can just
you can ping us wherever wherever we are
on social media share
or your photos just don't do so on a
Saturday because we certainly won't we
won't see it alright what else we have
going on oh we have several new writings
over at our website right now the
minimalists comm we're doing we're
cleaning up at the end of the year it's
time for end of year cleaning and there
are some new writings up there right now
about intentional living about simple
living some new rules for living with
less heading over to the minimalists
calm to check those out if you want to
comment on this episode you can do so
over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists also on youtube right now
we're doing quicky episodes of the
minimalist pot podcast little bite-sized
conversations about minimalism we're
also doing living room conversations
once a week and coming pretty soon we've
got some house tours for me and Ryan
it's just youtube.com slash the
minimalist and if you want our podcast
show notes to show up in your email
inbox then just head on over to our
website the minimalists com enter your
email address at the top any time a new
podcast episode comes out you will get
those show notes in your inbox also if
we write anything new any new writings
about minimalism those will show up in
your inbox as well but will never send
you any promotions advertisements or
spam because those things suck all right
Ryan what else you got for us I got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hi this is
Rachel Kalani from Newport Beach
my husband and I were recently at a
marriage event and the expert speakers
Doug fields shared his secret to a
fulfilling marriage or relationship he
said those relationships where both
people would rate their significant
other higher than their partners would
raise themselves are statistically the
happiest essentially just having
positive goggles to view your spouse or
partner through it's a pretty simple
concept but pretty profound
hi Josh and Ryan this is Laurie from
Walbridge Ohio I just want to make a
comment about items that we keep that
you call just in case or just for when I
also have items that I call it's only
when I go shopping I would get caught in
that trap of well it's only this amount
or well it's on sale it's only this and
I used to find myself buying things just
because well it's only and I want to
thank you for opening my eyes to living
more intentionally and realizing that I
don't always need to buy something
because it's only this is Jerry from
Kansas City thanks for your episode on
donations I'm simplifying and
decluttering and your podcasts on
donating inspired me I have a four
bedroom house for me and my 21 year old
son and I've managed to fill a pretty
full especially the closets in the
basement I don't have many items I'll
never use again another so you so rarely
that I don't get enough value to keep
the items I have 12 brothers and sisters
and over 30 nieces and nephews I decided
one of them might give value from the
items so I created a private Facebook
group for the Jerry clearance sale
everything our list is for sale or some
items for free to whoever wants it
proceeds from the sale will be donated
to charity and anything left over after
Halloween gets donated it's a light lift
with a deadline and I'm not trying to
sell items to people I don't know you
might not have good intentions all right
Joe that's it for this episode if you
have a question for the minimalists give
us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can all see e
mail a voice memo to podcasts at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
oh and let's let's play them out Ryan
with Khalid this is vertigo unless yeah
unless you're on YouTube then we'll put
a link to the the video enjoy
and minimus